after a hurricane of back and forth
leaks with Apple's 14 and 6 inch MacBook
Pros which were expected to get updated
this month yes November with new chips
and other updates we finally have the
truth we have confirmation with what's
gonna happen and they are getting
delayed but in this video I'm gonna
explain why that's actually the best
case scenario for these new Macbook Pros
because it points to something that I've
been speculating for months now and so
many people were going against me saying
that is wrong there's no way that could
happen but I think we finally have
confirmation and that's of course that
the new Macbook Pros are coming with new
three nanometer M2 Pro and M2 Max chips
so let's get started Mark German who is
the most reliable leaker out there just
came out with a new power on newsletter
letter saying that Apple's next Max are
delayed and set for early next year
based on the company's internal plans
and most recent earnings call comments
but before I dig into this newsletter
from Mark I want to point out that for
months now Mark believed that the new
Mac Mini and MacBook Pros would be
launching in November it's been like
that for months all the rumors pointed
to it but finally we have confirmation
that it is not happening from Mark
German himself with this new newsletter
so let's get right into it right here he
says that Apple's been gearing up for
the launch of some new Macs and now we
have a clear idea of one that will occur
early next year he's told that apple is
aiming to introduce the upgraded models
including M2 based versions of the 14
inch 16 inch MacBook Pros which is the
M2 Pro and M2 Max in the first quarter
of calendar
2023 and if you want a specific date
here it is he says Apple rarely launches
products in January or February so it's
gonna be in the first half of March
which actually aligns to what I've been
saying for months now which is perfect
and the reason he believes so strongly
in this delay is because Apple was
aiming to release it this fall but their
latest comments and their earnings call
confirms it when Tim Cook basically said
that the product line for their Max is
set for the holiday season which means
no new Max until next year but this
right here is my favorite part Apple
Also may be waiting until it can build
ships using the three nanometer process
the first M2 chips on the M1 are based
on five nanometer technology so it's
probably worth the wait yes you guys
just heard Mark German finally
acknowledge that these new M2 Pro and M2
Max chips could be built on three
nanometer instead of five Against All
Odds and against everybody who said
there's no way apple is gonna do this
Mark German just acknowledged it and
it's not only Mark German because we got
some other leaks from other sources
including the account ux 1122 on the
Korean blog Naver saying the supply
chain points to the 14 and 16 inch not
launching until early next year matching
up to what Mark German is saying and the
even more important piece to the three
nanometer puzzle is the fact that
markerman says that there's going to be
no new Max until 2023 including the Mac
Mini which I personally thought was
going to be launching in November for
sure but there is actually a very good
reason for the delay which I am going to
be getting into in just a minute so the
big question that we've got to figure
out is should you wait for the new M2
Pro and M2 Max MacBook Pros next year
well regardless of your decision our
sponsor basis sent us over the perfect
charger for the 14 or 16 inch MacBook
Pro this is their power combo 100 watt
power strip that comes with a nice five
foot long cable and it can charge up to
six devices using Dynamic power
allocation it offers up to a hundred
watts of fast charging to charge
something like the 16 inch MacBook Pro
like this one up to 33 in just 30
minutes but making it even better is the
fact that it has not one but two USBC
ports as well as two USB a ports to
charge a bunch of devices on your desk
but the Banger feature is that it also
has two AC Outlets so you can plug in
even more devices including these unique
battery chargers that we actually use
for our camera monitor for our top cam
the value of this thing is crazy good
because it costs less than other 100w
Chargers but unlike those it also comes
with the additional two AC outlets and
it comes with a USBC Cable in the box so
it's basically the best and most compact
charger I've seen for the price so go
ahead and check it out using the links
in the description and pin comment below
now getting back to why the delay of the
Mac Mini is so important to the three
nanometer puzzle we actually got some
brand new leaks from the Mac Rumors
Forum user amethyst check this out he
recently said that the coming Mac lineup
May cost a fortune saying that the 14
and 16 inch MacBook Pro with M2 Pro and
M2 Max will include very high bandwidth
high speed Ram which could make it more
expensive which might be a reason why
some of you might just buy this 14 or 6
inch MacBook Pro right now instead of
waiting but speaking of the Mac Mini he
said that the next Mac Mini will be a
simple M2 drop in which basically means
no redesign chassis it's going to look
the same which kind of makes sense
because the Mac Studio has the same
design as the old Mac Mini which is what
Mark German was saying but then amethyst
also came out with this Mac Rumors Forum
post saying that the Mac Mini is going
to be an incremental upgrade with the
same design basically the same Parts but
a change in the soc slash threads that
basically means that we can expect the
M2 Chip but not only that because the
Mansion of threads means that it could
be two different choices of the M2 so
the empty chip and the M2 Pro chip which
other sources have been saying for
months including mark gurman saying that
we could have the choice between both of
those and I fully believe that it's
going to take an M2 Pro Mac Mini to
fully replace the Intel model that's for
sale for over a thousand dollars so if
Apple wants people to pay that price
it's got to be the M2 Pro and now let's
get into why that is so important that
Apple completely delayed the Mac Mini
both the M2 Pro and the regular M2
versions check this out I recently made
a video four months ago saying that
Apple's M2 Pro MacBooks will be better
than you think and the whole point of
that video was that it would be based on
three nanometer chip technology from
tsmc which is called N3 thin flex and
you might be thinking that I'm crazy and
that it's pure speculation but there are
a ton of leaks that pointed to those
chips the M2 Pro and M2 Max being based
on three nanometer check this out way
back in June tsmc themselves said that
their three nanometer chips are
launching an early
2023. you can see their chart right here
from tsmc saying that in 2022 N3 would
begin production which is those three
nanometer chips and guess what already
already happened in August it was
reported that tsmc was beginning three
nanometer chip production next month
which was in September so tsmc is
already working on these three nanometer
chips but check this out way back in
June we got our first report from Jeff
Pooh saying that tsmc was going to start
mass production of new three nanometer
M2 Pro chip later this year not five
nanometer three nanometer and not only
that but shrimp Apple Pro who was the
first one to leak the new camera design
with the dynamic Island for the iPhones
he himself in June said that the M2 Pro
and Max will get three nanometer yes he
confirmed it himself and even in July he
confirmed yes to somebody asking if the
M2 Pro Max are gonna be three nanometer
and then once again in August taiwan's
commercial times themselves said the 3
nanometer M2 Pro chip for the MacBook
Pro was entering production but it
doesn't stop there because digit times
said the same thing Apple's first three
nanometer chips expected to enter
production this year and then later in
August there were rumors that tsmc was
abandoning their three nanometer process
but the CEO confirmed and said that the
process is far from canceled they're
working on it and the M2 Pro and M2 Max
are likely to be on three nanometer and
then finally just last month on October
24th Apple has reportedly given tsmc a
large order to mass produce its M2 Pro
M2 Max and future socs on the latest
three nanometer process look at all of
those leaks pointing to the M2 Pro and
M2 Max on three nanometer not five
nanometer and I believe that is why Mark
German is finally acknowledging the
possibility of these chips being based
on three nanometer and that may be why
app apple is waiting they're waiting
until those chips are ready which tsmz
said is only happening in early 2023 so
all of the puzzle pieces are finally
coming together including my own
personal thoughts on the actual Apple
silicon update cycle being an 18 month
cycle which would be perfect because
this MacBook Pro the 16-inch came out in
November of 2021 and 18 months after
that is basically spring or March of
2023 perfectly falling in line and being
right on time for three nanometer chips
so because of all of that and Apple's
delay of these MacBook Pros until next
year I am now 100 sure that those new M2
Pro and M2 Max chips will be built on
three nanometer Against All Odds and
because of that they are going to be in
absolutely killer upgrade they're going
to be more efficient the battery life is
going to be a lot better they're not
going to overheat they're going to be
able to use full performance without
having crazy fan noise or Apple's just
basically going to be able to give
insane amounts of power to them if they
choose to I think those three nanometer
chips are going to be worth the weight
and worth the upgrade but it's gonna
come at a cost because Apple could raise
the price so if you're not willing to
pay more than these MacBooks which start
at 2000 for the 14 inch and 2500 for the
16 inch then maybe it's a better choice
for you to just buy this one right here
because it's currently on sale on Amazon
for a crazy good deal and you don't have
to wait so if you don't care that much
about three nanometer it could be worth
it just to buy it right now for the
better sale price but if you disagree
with me on anything in this video let me
know in the comments section below and
if you learned something new click the
circle above to subscribe right there
and check out one of those two videos
right there the thanks again basis for
sponsoring this video this thing's
actually really sick thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video
[Music]